39块扣个1
39扣个1
来这一个M嘛
据日捐日
这个是一个黑色
黑色带灰色角碎花
还有一个灰色
这个是一个黑色带灰色花
来外搭雪红的胸围
胸围是110 114
110 114
来这个长度
长度的话是101
长度101
这个9块
9块扣0
9块9块扣0扣0
小外搭一个雪红
可以当防晒也可以
如果你穿的那个叫
背心吊带或者小短裙啥的
外面搭一个这个防晒扣好了
9块
9块扣1扣1
9块扣个1
来这个藏蓝色的
藏蓝色一款小上衣
微领微领的这一款
来胸围
胸围的话是94 108
94 108来这个长度
长度48
9块9块扣8扣8
这样子的
这样的一个面料超稳的一样
来这个9块钱
扣8扣8这一个
9块扣个8扣个8
9块钱扣个8
mik1的又穿一个这个
这个花型
看看这都是早几天刚来的新款
mik1的一个m嘛
面料好舒服
丝滑的很
这个腰带也不少也有腰带
这个也是有腰带
可以当裙可以当长款上衣
两个花型了
现在是胸围98118
98118胸围长度是80的
长度80这个59扣0
59 59扣0扣0
一个这个紫
呃这个属于咖色的底
然后这个还有一个
蓝色的紫色花
蓝色底59 59
都有腰带不少
面料都是很丝滑很舒服的了
59扣8
59扣8扣8
59块扣扣8
来这一款卫衣
原来呢
这种卫衣都给你们放超低福利了
有能穿到闭眼扣
原来都是39的卫衣
后面有胶印前面有字母
来这个胸围
胸围
晚安
你你不是早上给你弄好了吗
早饭
就你节期做饭吗
那你做饭了吧
你给我说啥
那你早上饭你穿了吗
宝子穿了吗
不行
你那不还有了吗
你那我
咋没有了
你上回买了没穿了
我也不知道你那宝子能穿了吗
嗯
把你作业完成了去
作业完成了再卷
我不见你那五来还有你那保留的呢
那穿了吗
可得
来胸围140-160
140-160
来这个衣裳啊
没有你说的齿的
我不知道长度71啊
这个9块尺码大
这个大男生可以穿9块扣1扣1啊
哎
等你写好作业了再去啊
我今天给你布置作业你完成了吗
啊
这个我走我闹二十啊
你把作业完成了再去
来这一款
这个是细线针织的一个背心裙
啊
细线针织的一款背心裙长款的长款
这个上面都是粗纱线
这是啥问题
这个也没看见是啥问题
上面都有好多小线头呢
好多小线头是定位的
是干啥的
在这个位置
粗纱线有一丢丢不明显
哎
挂了啊
来这个胸围
这个胸围
胸围的话
是94-130
94-130的胸围
来这个长度
长度是120
长度120
这个19
19给你们扣0扣0
线头应该有定位的有粗纱线有一丢丢
来这个
29块
1919扣0扣0
背心裙真知道长得很
这个原来买49的
一眼扣吧
1919扣0扣0
19块扣个0
哇
平时这个被其实想走到时候他不出来
今天不走了
他一样出来三件了
你看看
苹果给你了
这个9块
来
小黄油
粗纱线剪成这个笔
我的妈呀
这个笔怎么成这样的了
370370谢谢
扣好了这个
扣好了
来来来来
线头你自己回去拆一下就行
其实应该都是定
我感觉都是定位的比较多
划算
给你检查一下
OK
大约370
你们看看7 μου
好
谢谢
来这个背心春夏秋都能穿
这个是镂空的
平时有人要说我一个没走到那天
好几天了
这个这个么多这么久了
好像我
最早得有两个礼拜了
这个也没过过
今天压了出来3件
来这个 胸围88-120 长度56
9块钱给你们 扣6扣6
人面辉仿的这个线是一个细线 真是看没细的很 而且弹力很大
哎 摸马吃腿应该是来这个19块钱还19呢
这个原来买29的 一直卖放福利是19的 给你们9块了 9块9块 应该是哪天谁卖错价了 我看有卖9块
扣3 扣3 这个9块钱 扣个3
9块扣3
春夏秋冬能穿 夏天在空调房 这个穿整好
很好 来这个 这个棉的一个牛仔裤 棉95捐着5
来腰围 腰围68-74 腿围88-98
当长34 裤长88 来这个有钥的扣
来这个9块 9块扣8 白色白色
和那个蓝色和那个咖色 昨天或前天了
三个颜色都出来 今天出来一个短的 是一个白色
八九分七八分的一个程度 七八分的一个程度
9块9块 年95捐着5
9块扣8 9块扣个8
9块减 扣8扣8
9块9块 来这个克兰伊兰的一个背心
克兰伊兰的一个背心
猪猪的 咱们洗一下 咱们说就开了
胸围
胸围是88-100
88-100的胸围 长度 长度是88
这个9块
9块扣5
9块9块 扣个5
看看
是这样子的
9块9块 扣5 扣5
承开来很大这个
9块9块 扣个5 扣个5
来这一块
这个也好看
单穿打底 我感觉这个外面套个马甲也好看
肩膀上好多小珍珠 这个公主肩的
牌子是这个牌子
可以当打底
当打底
单穿都好看 这个肩膀
公主肩这种
来 胸围
胸围的话是96-118
96-118 长度
长度是59 长度59
来这个19块
扣0 扣0
19-19 扣个0
19 这个不好了
这个袖子还在哪里
身上
合缝的地方
腰 腰这个底下合缝的旁边你看没 这样子的
这样子的线很细
好像
线没这么密了
织的问题
9块 9块
9块 9块 你可以当打底
可以当打底 穿个马甲在里面就看不到了 在这个位子
看没 在这里
合缝这个边上这一点
织的问题呢 织的特稀着一点点
织的线比较少 感觉这一点
9块
9块 扣个1
穿个马甲 正好在这个地方
腰上这个位子 看不见了
9块 9块
不是那个的地方 这个版型很好
9块 扣1 扣1
多好看这个
9块 扣扣1
把我的那个拿过来
把这两个给我哥
9块钱
有腰的不 都好看这个
给它放一边 等会我再做过
孤品了
剩了一个孤品
来
这个是一个学纺 学纺的一个定义
学纺 学纺呢
前面 前面一个牌扣子 金属的小白扣子
金属的一个小白扣
学纺 学纺这一件
来 修尾
修尾
修尾是92 100
92 100
来 长度
长度64
9块 9块
扣0 扣0
9块 扣0 扣0
9块钱 9块钱
学纺的这件衬衣 孤品 孤品了
来这个
这个底下有个小洞呢
看看
看看这种
这个在边上合缝的地方
有一点点不太好
来这个
这个原价是39
镂空的一个大衬衣
SUR1V1的这一块
看看镂空的
来
胸尾116 136
116 136
长度75
这个9块扣8
9块扣个8
这个在后背上
后面这个位置
看见没
9块9块
这里有一丢丢小苹果
这里有一点点不太好
在哪里
在这里
看见没
后面
后面这里这样子的
看见没
有一点点
后面底下有一丢
9块37
哦
有黄油
来37
好
谢谢
我再给你检查一下其他地方
来
OK
其他没问你
这边有一点
好
谢谢
来这一块
是啥
这个是啥
哎
Several
이거
Troy
太好了
大家好
大家
骛
你
好好
大家
好
함
哈
vehicle
左
这
右
左右
对
左
胸围
胸围106